if you've ever thought about becoming a
real estate agent there is added
incentive to do so now Kirby Scofield of
Schofield Realty the sponsors of this
segment joins us to talk about that you
are offering a bonus for someone whether
they have experience or they're brand
new to become a realtor with your team
that is correct so Kendall we are
offering 2500 agent signing bonus so I
came up with it uh hit us up to see if
you qualify if your new agent haven't
sold anything been a referral only agent
or an experienced agent so there's other
options too and that is a process in and
of itself to become an agent but yes
that would be a big boost a big leg up
and trying to get there oh yeah so who
doesn't want free money yeah and the
money doesn't come from the split
doesn't come from seller side buyer side
is directly from my pocket from my side
of the split and uh paid once you
qualify for it so I don't know other
brokerages out there offering currently
and that's why I wanted to come up with
something different and also to attract
more talent to the team because we are
exploding right now well that says
something about not only how your
business is doing but how the market is
doing as well yeah it's blowing up next
week we'll talk on this new rate thing
that we all got word of once I get more
key points from Robert Kimber group our
partner lender because I want to make
sure I know what I'm talking about
because I was kind of dumbfounded myself
when I heard of it so but with that we
need more agents yesterday and instead
of just saying oh come join us we're so
cool we're going to pay you to join not
a bad incentive at all so the market is
going so well that for a while there was
um additional inventory or more than we
had experience at the past that's
shrinking right now uh yeah so as of
this week and it's been turning this way
three months straight it is trending
down which means the price is going to
see prices raising it's just economics
um
if you're in the pocket price three to
five hundred thousand and you're
thinking about buying start offering now
and that's the cat and mouse game
because people want to try to time the
market if they're if they're selling
their house of course they want to sell
at the peak and if you're buying a house
you don't want to buy it at the peak the
good thing is you haven't really lost
money if you're selling your house and
you bought it in the last 13 years that
I've been licensed and if you're buying
you're going to buy what you can afford
and what you need so historically
speaking if long term it's a good
investment a long term wait out I mean
spend six to eight different markets in
my 13 years yeah so it's always up and
down if you're in a fixed rate mortgage
uh just make sure it's within what you
can afford you have nothing to lose
depending because we never know what's
going to happen ever but always need
good agents and with that we train uh we
have the mentorship the resources and
everything to make sure they are
representing the client correctly and
we're going to pay them extra to be part
of us well that's just a big perk right
there because of your experience and
everything probably funneling some
business all that it makes a big
difference if you're just starting out
or transferring to another agency ah
correct and uh we're excited for this
summer coming all right appreciate you
being here it's always good to have you
with us thank you thank you to Scofield
Realty for sponsoring this segment and
they are looking for new Talent we
talked about the 2500 signing bonus
there are some terms that apply you can
learn all about it by calling that phone
number on the screen
702-766-3795 or go to the website
schofieldrealty.com